[Music]
there are some people there asking okay
how do i do this same thing on windows
i can answer that but i also just want
to show you something that you should
know if you're a programmer
especially on windows hopefully this
helps someone that is totally stuck and
doesn't understand this sort of thing
so to start out i'm just going to open
terminal this is windows terminal but
it's essentially
going to be the same if you're using
command line or powershell or
approximately the same might be tiny
differences
the new windows terminal looks a little
something like this and it says
powershell i guess it's mainly operating
off powershell
but it has commands from linux uh to
some extent like
for example we have ls normally with
command line you have to use directory
so they added some little shortcuts and
things like that
into this new terminal but that doesn't
fix
problems like what if you type cmake
here and try to do your cmake command
and it just doesn't work well mine finds
it says usage and stuff
what if it just says not found and same
with git what if you try to do git stuff
here and it just says not found mine
doesn't say not found as you can see
but i can make it say not found yours
might work fine and if it does it's
because you either already edited your
path or when you installed cmake or
git or whatever it was you checked the
box that said add this to my path
variables so if you check that box this
is already done but if you didn't check
that box
which i believe by default it's left
unchecked so if you just left everything
default
you won't be able to use these from your
terminal
so i'm going to hit my start button type
in let's just type in path
that's good enough so you want to find
edit the system environment variables
there's a million different ways to get
to this on windows
just type in paths after hitting start
is one of the easiest in my opinion
and just open this up it's in your
system properties under advanced it
automatically goes there
and you just click environment variables
so what we see here is two different
sets of things
have environment variables for your
account so when you're logged in to your
account which i'm logged into matt
yeah so i'm logged in as matt so i have
all these environment variables but then
you have ones that are just for your
system in general
so you have one of them labeled path
right here and that's the main one we're
going to focus on today
and you can either double click on it
and you can see the full list of them
or you can click edit see the full list
of them
and you can also do the same thing down
here you'll see path
and you can edit them for this is
basically for everybody anybody who uses
your computer now
you have to kind of decide whether you
want things in your user environments or
in your system environments
i typically do it in system if it's like
something that
in general should be available to
everyone and if it's just my own
personal thing i'll do it in my own
and now for the hot trick yes you hit
edit
you can see in here there is get there's
cmake occasionally you'll just have to
make corrections in here too
if something goes buggy too so let's go
ahead and remove git and cmake
because those are going to be examples
delete delete
okay okay okay we gotta restart the
terminal
it's pretty normal for your terminal to
not see changes until you restart it so
now if i type it
yeah it has no idea and this is where
people often get stuck they're like i
haven't installed i
i don't know why i i don't want to have
to use the the gui
every time for cmake i want to just do a
command line well you have to add it to
your path
that's the big thing so let's go back in
here
type in path go back to environment
variables look for
path there's path edit the path
and this is where you need to make sure
you add it so let's put that in there
it's just program files
slash get slash bin
and there's also one for cmake you could
essentially do this for anything you
could do this for your batch files if
you want to just be able to run them
from the command line
okay relaunch the terminal type c make
and it now works i get and it now works
so now you can go about using cmake from
the command line and you can go about
using git
from the command line
now a big difference from my linux
tutorials and you know linux cmake i was
doing most of that work on linux
so i was mostly using the gcc
compiler so windows doesn't have the gcc
compiler
you can install wsl
and that will give you the gcc compiler
you can also use ming gw which i believe
someone left a comment about
he's pointing to his source pointing to
where it wants to build but also a dash
g for generator
in his ming gw generator make files
so you can do that if you're using a
ming gw
compiler all right so just going to see
makes
a website there's a bunch of different
ones for a bunch of different compilers
here
so you got to know which compiler you're
using which how you want your make file
process and all that if you have visual
studio and that compiler all installed
you can do the dash g with one of these
visual studio versions
so now you should be able to path to
your source and run
cmake on your source and and do stuff
with it let me see if i can get a little
example here for you guys
make a directory called just test
all right very good so let's go into
test here
and let's put some code in here in a
make file and see if we can get
visual studio to generate okay so i went
ahead and made a few files
here just echoed in some return zero on
the main for
main.cpp and i just made a quick cmake
file
right here that just uh just says add
executable basically it has some new
lines
let's make sure all these look fine so
we can still launch visual studio code
here and let's just take a look at these
make sure they came out okay
looks like it didn't take the new lines
correctly so i
am going to just go ahead and manually
fix this up a little bit one of the
things about
visual studio code is i believe it's not
going to see
cmake unless you have it in your path
so i think that's one of the places
where people get stuck someone recently
asked
how do i set up libraries with visual
studio code
and i would say the easiest way is to
just use cmake's
library management stuff you can set it
up so that it talks to the libraries
from vc package manager
and that might be the easiest way if a
lot of people really want to see that
video i could show you how to do it step
by step
but we're going to stick to the project
at hand here
let's go ahead and just say hello world
in here though because just to know that
it
ran so if we run this we should get all
that good stuff so what we can do here
to run
cmake cmake dash source is where we are
dash build let's let's make a build
folder
and and we need to specify
our generator so we're going to use the
visual studio one
and it looks like it's not happy about
something
file starts with byte order mark that is
not utf-8
configuring incomplete errors occurred
okay so it's not happy with our files
however it did try to run you can see it
made the build folder did some cache
stuff here
let's figure this out i guess we gotta
figure out this utf thing let me just
google it a little bit
but basically we let's just remake it
here
copy all this text delete this and just
remake it here
so we'll just try the same command again
there we go now it's happy very weird
bug so yeah you'll occasionally
run into stuff like that and you just
gotta figure out how to fix it
so here we go you can see it working
here it found the source
build folder and it selected the
windows as our generator so it is now
grabbing all the information from the
latest one so you can use any of these
generators
once you have the cmake set up to do the
same thing on windows that i
showed on basically all those cmake
tutorials
before i was using linux so let's see
what we got here
we got a test.solution okay it hasn't
compiled yet
so we can either open it with visual
studio or we can compile it from here
it looks like it's just under your
program files and in this bin folder you
will find
an application so this is the path
we're going to need for what we want to
do so let's add this
to our system environment variables
path so there's our new path all the way
to ms build current ben
hit okay hit okay hit okay and now
let's see if we can invoke ms build oh
we got to restart this thing
right let's see if it sees ms build
it does okay so now we should be able to
run uh
ms build on our project and build it
and uh there's a lot to this i'm really
giving it a very
simplified overview so after i'm done
i'll show you
some documentation you can go to if you
want to read further
but first let's get back to our project
we do a directory well we're in the same
directory that we have open in our
editor
and we've already generated the whole
thing so now all we need to do is build
that
uh solution or project let's do an ms
build
uh star dot solution test.solution see
what happens
now i would expect this to build
everything and there we go it did build
there were zero warnings two errors so i
was reading that you have to do it on a
project like a vc project but i guess on
the solution works too on a solution
it's probably just going to build
everything
you can see it left all the defaults
like debug and stuff like that so you
can change this you can pass it options
and i'm not going to do that here but
i'll show you where you can read more
about that if you want to mess with that
kind of stuff so now we should be able
to actually run our file that's like the
next thing we want to do let's take a
look let's see if we can find test
executable in here somewhere oh it's
going to be here
under this debug not x64 debug but just
debug all right now
let's run test.exe
and it didn't find it
oh i typed in text and there we go we
get our hello world
all using cmake visual studio code
and compiling with microsoft visual
studio compiler
hopefully this helps you going forward
and i hope you all have
a super good new year special shout out
to my patreons
i would love if more people would join
this year
we have a private discord where we chat
and and figure out
things and that's where you can get sort
of advanced access to me where i will
talk about a lot more than i normally
would and answer your questions and
so if you want to be involved in a new
coding and video editing and technology
community in general
uh feel free to do that you just got to
be any level member
and what else i feel like there's
something else i don't know i guess i
just want to say thanks guys i really
appreciate all the people that watch
and all that stuff and i always feel
weird saying this but
it's true like it's definitely
it's well it's definitely changed my
life in ways that i didn't expect i
never really expected to have
a successful or i'm not i don't want to
say successful but
you know just a channel that people even
watched i was kind of just playing
around when i started
all right well i'm gonna call it i'll
see you guys later
peace out and keep coding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you